jeremy chef what is your barbecue
style one would want to know style
i i don't have a style i mean i just
make a bunch of different stuff i
look i i'm i'm trying it's a process
it's it's a hobby uh
you know i've got one of those big green
eggs it's like a cult
i hope somebody's listening from the
company and i get some kind of
sponsorship
i post all this stuff on instagram so
all my
dozens of followers of me
it's fun you know i i like to cook rich
doesn't cook does he
he makes great scrambled eggs he makes
delicious pancakes
and he makes me a drink at five
skeptical i'm skeptical
i you know i don't see rick really as
having that kind of patience
um and really it comes down to patience
um and you really there's something
innate
i mean you can you can only go so far
in terms of teaching someone how to cook
or grill or barbecue
i think there has to be a kind of sixth
sense for it
and i think i had that if anybody would
have
a sixth sense for grilling and cooking i
would imagine it would be you
we are we are looking at this is really
a thrill i mean that was quite a way to
welcome me into the show
um it's have i ever been on the show
when you've been
hosting before i don't i think this is
uh i i i mean i
i've wanted to do it for a long time but
i think this is the first time you're
having me
it's a hot ticket in town i'm just
saying you know the list is live
jeremy anybody can be on with rich this
is this is a whole different level
i i try to bring jeremy shap a whole
different level when i guest host the
rich eisen show
out of sheer fear that they won't let me
come back so i try to
i try to bring it with me we are looking
at photographs of you though
um we of course doctored them and put on
a chef's hat
and a chef's smock um curious for what
recipe you could share with the rich
eisen
listeners that we can then post on
social media what is your go to one
of those things that i like to do um you
know
the kind of thing like if you're a
beginner i think it's really almost
infallible um
is if you're doing let's say baby back
ribs
uh the classic three uh two
one oh wait no no two two one no you're
right two one for baby back it's three
two one jeremy you're right you're on it
you guys
know st louis style is three two one the
bigger ones
the baby back or two to one
i think because six hours is too much
for the baby backs
the st louis style this is this is great
radio susie um are the three two one so
it's
it's two hours of smoking and then you
take them off and what i do is i wrap
them in foil and i pour in
some you know typically apple juice or
beer something like that
and then you wrap them in the foil put
them back on for two hours getting
really steamy
soft and then you take it off and you
put some kind of you know barbecue sauce
some kind of lacquer on it
and put them directly back on the grates
um for the final you know 45 minutes to
an hour
and it you can't go wrong you can't go
wrong it doesn't take a lot of prep you
don't have to
you know marinate it overnight you don't
have to salt it overnight anything like
that you just put on your rub
you know you gotta you gotta um peel off
that membrane
which sometimes people forget to do you
don't have to but
i prefer to peel off the membrane it's
an important step for sure it's
important
it is right and you slather it with some
mustard so the rubs
you know uh has
jeremy do you want to do a cooking show
with me let's do a cooking show together
wouldn't that be fun trying to for years
i'd love to do a cooking show i really
would kind of a
you know a cultural food show you get to
travel and eat all over the world but
doesn't everybody want to do that like
wait a minute wait a minute wait a
minute go with me here it you and i host
it right
and it's about the greatest food per
sports town
so we go to all the different sports
towns we ask the
fans to send us to the right restaurant
we then interview
the chefs i then screw up trying to make
it
and you do it beautifully and you give
it historical perspective
and i get to eat because i mean i mean i
you know we've been we've had a lot of
meals together over the years we've
spent a lot of time together
um i don't think of you and i say this
with all due respect as really an eater
i mean you're you're pretty skinny i
mean and
um oh jeremy i've never loved you more
than ever
what are you trying to say chris that
with me i thought yeah i would take it
that says you know
i'm questioning your bonafides as as a
real eater
and you know you know you're from
boston originally i'm from new york it's
more of a food town i i think of myself
as really more of the
um person who focuses on the next meal
as soon as you've just finished the last
meal if you like
that is true you're kind of like okay
about it it's not
it's not an obsession with you maybe
that's good to bring a different kind of
perspective to it
cause you know
mouth-watering all the time at the
thought of the next meal well you know
what i make
really really well reservations
reservations
jeremy shap suzy schuster here on the
rich eisen show
jeremy you're you're mr perspective so
that's what i like to have your mr
perspective you have great perspective
on everything so your mr perspective one
of your myriad nicknames
let's talk about a couple news
ideas here and one of them is of course
the logo in the nba
what's your take on the possibility of
replacing jerry west with a modern
player maybe kobe bryant maybe another
one
well it's interesting so um and i hope i
get the story exactly right
but uh we're gonna go very deep
background and perspective on this susie
so i don't know
whoever knew um my friend stacy siegel
from college that i went to college with
did you ever know stacy i think i met
her once like 20 years ago
michael bloom so so stacy's father is a
guy named alan siegel
uh who grew up with my father on long
island and i think
alan's father and alan's mother rather
and my grandmother were best friends
anyway allen see a long story short
uh he also went to cornell and he became
a very successful
brand marketing logo person like you
know
you'd go to him and he created a name
for a company
uh he would create your logo and i guess
like your marketing strategy very
successful
and he is the guy who created the nba
logo
oh wow um whenever whenever that
happened to be
so i i think it was the late 60s right
maybe it was the mid 60s
and um and i guess
you know jerry west it was kind of thing
like where it was alan said it was jerry
west but it was never kind of officially
jerry west it was just
presented that way and it's a great logo
um
it's been a great logo for a long time
um
but i understand the desire to update it
and to um you know to honor kobe bryant
one of the great players in the history
of the game
and you know if they end up doing it and
i don't know where it stands i heard
there was you know some talk about doing
it recently
uh in the last few days uh you know i i
like the idea of the symmetry from west
to bryant you know the guy who drafted
him the guy who brought him to the
lakers the guy who was his mentor
so close to him uh playing the same
you know both guards the same team and
and
you know i think um the brokers get
updated all the time
uh they they they
they changed the design they update them
for whatever reason make them more
modern
more appealing more relevant i i
i think that makes sense um uh
you know is there
i guess the question is you know
permanence what should be permanent what
shouldn't change what are the things
that we expect to
just remain the same and there are very
few things like that right
in life and certainly when we're talking
about
these kinds of symbols um uh which are
which exists after all uh to market
something
to sell something uh you know the
product of the nba
and uh and at the same time to honor the
heritage of the game
and to honor the best players so if it's
going to change
makes sense to do it with kobe bryant
i think it makes perfect sense and also
because it has that
double on ton of providing an homage to
kobe who meant so much to
the current generation of players
because if you look at jerry west
some so if he played what 62 63 around
then
and then so the kids who are coming up
in the in the jordan era they
they knew jerry i think that the kids
were playing now when i say kids because
i'm 48 so i can say kids
but they grew up worshiping kobe and
to lose him the way that we all lost him
it would seem to me to be the perfect
symbolic
gesture the question now will be as we
talked about earlier
um then royalties get involved because
jerry west never received a dime for
being the logo so
to speak and the question is would it
then become a huge
monetary output if they change the logo
oh really so so it would be the kind of
thing where if his likeness is
used his estate would get royalties
is that is that what they're saying i
think that's the understanding
uh you know and i i think it's a great
time
for me to call adam silver i guess after
the show and ask him because you would
think at this point if they use a
likeness
you have to pay the estate but it seems
to me that it's
the right thing to do
makes sense makes sense to me i mean i i
don't i don't know anything about the
economics other than i certainly don't
know anything about you know the
copyright law
you have to know everything about
everything jeremy shaft everything
i could fake it but yeah that that makes
sense to me
and you know i again i mean i remember
growing up with
you know logos for different teams for
different leagues whatever it might be
and they adapt they evolve they change
and
uh and jerry west as as the
silhouette of the nba is that a great
run
that's just the thought we had that's
just something that occurs to us and
we'll do a little bit of deep diving
after the show
jeremy shop here on the rich eisen show
i'm susie shuster sitting in for rich
i was really moved by your tiger woods
piece yesterday on espn
obviously we're all sitting here
wondering uh the accident happened shear
miles from our studio here in el segundo
and we're all wondering um what's next
for tiger woods but your your piece as
always was just beautifully written
and i'm curious to hear about your oh
you're welcome i'm here
curious to hear your thoughts on on this
as you watch and
and what occurs to you well you know i
think it's
um it's the way most people feel right
the
way the vast majority of people looking
at this must feel that uh
he's fortunate to be alive emerging from
that kind of a wreck
that kind of a crash um
that our first thought has to be about
um being able to lead a normal life to
be healthy and to walk
and to do the things that he was able to
do before this happened
on tuesday morning uh and then you think
about the scope of his career
and the arc of his life over the last 25
years
and and you think about how long he has
been a presence
in our lives and how we've seen these
remarkable
ups uh these these incredible highs
peaks and athletic careers that are
unsurpassed really
uh certainly in the 21st century in the
late 20th century
um but you know one of one of the few
athletes you know when you
throw around the word icon it's it's
understatement
with with tiger woods um and then we've
also seen
you know his struggles in in the events
of thanksgiving weekend 2009
and how um that changed the narrative
around tiger woods in a flash in a
moment
and this this sudden fall from grace
and then um the physical struggles that
would come later with his back
and uh the times when it seemed like he
would never really be able to
uh beat tiger woods on the golf course
again
in that remarkable victory two years ago
at the masters after
an 11 year interval between his 14th and
his 15th
grand slam wins uh major titles
um you know it's it's a remarkable
um novelistic story and
life but there's a person at the center
of it and
and you know it was when i heard the
news a couple days ago
um susie about i guess it was around a
little before three o'clock eastern time
um you know by that time i
what i was being told and i think
everybody was hearing was that these
were not
life-threatening and so you know there's
immediately
um release there and you know you know
you can take a breath
okay he's he's going to be
okay he's going to live and but this is
these are very serious injuries from
you know what we're hearing and the
doctors you know we've been consulting
and um we don't know if he's ever going
to be able to play golf again
and and of course that's secondary to
the larger story
but i'm also thinking about
two months ago when he played at the pnc
championship with charlie
and um that that kind of image that
sticks in my mind now
of tiger woods um wow seeming
seeming comfortable in a way you know on
camera and with the media
and and kidding around and having fun
with his 11 year old son
and how we were seeing uh a new side of
tiger he was allowing us to see a
different side of himself
and um that relationship with the media
that had been at times so adversarial
and uh you know obviously you know four
years ago we're talking about
um you know those images of him getting
pulled over
or asleep on the side of the road you
know
and the the things that he has had to
deal with and the mistakes that he has
made
and then um the physical challenges it's
just
there's so much there and all we can
hope for
it's it's trite but what could be more
um essential that he's just okay
uh i can't say enough about that and
about the fact that i look at the
pictures of him with charlie and all i
think about are kobe and gianna so we
are
as you said so so grateful that he will
come out of this
and hopefully make some kind of recovery
you think about ben hogan too right i
mean you think about um
you know the car accident the crash that
ben hogan was in in 1949 and
you know he was a younger man at that
point than tiger woods
is now i think hogan was 35 at the time
of that
crash in west texas um which left him in
the hospital i think for 59 days
you know it's different scenario but
when you're talking about two of the
five or six greatest golfers of all time
maybe two or the three greatest golfers
of all time
um both having uh both surviving
crashes like that you know you have to
draw parallels
jeremy thank you as always for your
perspective your time and your recipes
come back every single time i'm on
please i will
i will invited or otherwise i'm always
happy to have you crash jeremy thanks
again for your time
thanks guys hey you watched all the way
to the end thanks for that
watch more right here